christine that's security video coming
from the popular student bar
behind me here on mlk and menlo and
while the judge declared the student
innocent
he is not out of the clear just yet he
says he now has to prove himself to a
usc
ethics committee that will ultimately
decide whether or not he can stay here
for the fall semester well i was very
surprised that these charges would be
brought against me because
i hadn't done anything wrong usc student
armon premgee
charged with rape after a night out at
an off campus bar
but he says security video from the
night of april first
taken from banditos shows he's innocent
when i saw the videos i was very
relieved that there was proof
to substantiate my side of the story
the video shows premgee and a female
student kissing in the bar's back corner
her arms around his neck premji said she
kept pulling him closer
and after several minutes she led him by
the hand out of the bar
on the sidewalk premji said the girl
introduced him to her roommate
where she made sexual gestures behind
his back she made a gesture to her
friend
of her plans to have intercourse with me
that night premji says
they had both been drinking the two are
seen leaving in an uber before arriving
to the girl's dorm room
security video there shows the alleged
victim stopping to sign him in
after i had sex with her i left and the
next day the lapd was at my doorstep
asking me about you know what happened
premgie says the alleged victim
never reported the incident to police
but he was charged with rape after he
says her roommates gave officers his
name
premgy said the girl was the aggressor
and last saturday a judge agreed
after seeing the video cleared him of
all charges
hearing the judge give a ruling you know
it made us
believe that there is justice truth does
come out ultimately and we were
fortunate to
have the kind of evidence to support you
know armand's innocence
but premji's innocence will have to be
proven once again
he says usc's office of equity and
diversity
is conducting its own investigation i
could get suspended or expelled from
from the university even though the
judge has declared me innocent
meantime he says he's supposed to pay
fall tuition
start classes and then wait for their
decision
we reached out to the university but
didn't hear by news time tonight
your thoughts well what people are going
to say i know and already i
can hear it we don't know what happened
in the room and i understand that we
don't know what happened in the room
she could have said no in the room and
he kept on going i can i can understand
that
but if you look at the law there is
reasonable doubt especially that she
made gestures
of you want
to it's not even the doubt there's the
cases dropped
right there give me two seconds the
cases drop right there when the girl
wanted what they expelled him
but abba nobody has a reason to do such
a thing
here's the thing like i said like i was
saying
we don't know what happened in the room
and stuff but that happened
right now it brings about admission to
school and the school doesn't have to go
by what the law says
we don't really her hear anything about
her we don't know what her name is we
don't know anything about that there's
nothing that happens with that we don't
know what
why was he expelled i don't know people
always talk
talk about yo why would someone do that
there's
none of the cases the keys are reported
it shows only like
this that's what i mean by reported she
didn't report rape to the police
it doesn't count and things like that
happen but she reported man
there's so much things to unravel in
this
it's really crazy i understand like like
i said
that what people looking to say that we
don't know what happened and she could
have changed her mind
but then again i got to go with what the
law says with the
with the standard that the law put of
reasonable doubt
and there's reasonable doubt if the
police dropped it
you're gonna expel him on the basis of
what
i don't know man expelling him
and then what happens to her he's known
as a rapist we don't know her name we
don't know nothing about that right
there's a double standard there's a
double there's a double everything on
that
and if i was someone that is pushing for
the metoo movement and pushing for the
believer movement
i would be pissed off because this right
there discredits everything that you're
working for
i'd be pissed at her not at him not at
us
at her she's the one messing up with
your game
she's the one messing up what you're
thinking what you work so hard for
i'd be pissed off at her what you got to
say about that
no there's not much to to really add
really
it's uh i didn't get angry about stuff
like this anymore i don't get bothered
by it i'm just like
listen as a dude i'm gonna just give you
guys advice she's drunk don't do it
she drank don't do it
she can make up a whole bunch of facts
then she could get proven wrong
showing that she was the one who was the
aggressor she was the one who's showing
all the hints
she was the one that was leading him
everywhere and then she said well i was
drunk i don't
remember you know that's why i say me if
a girl drinks
get out i don't even entertain it not
even thinking about it
and i know there's a god dip i'm just
telling you guys this for your own
protection
she drinks don't even think about it
don't even consider it
another thing is say yo vet the people
you're gonna get with
he took a drunken hookup didn't know was
gonna end up this way
hey vet the people you get with as best
as you can i know i've made that mistake
in the past before
definitely not gonna do that again so
vet the people you get with and the last
thing i would say is this even if it's
not
necessarily like you know there's no
good answer to this stuff
you know you have something that's like
you know rightly so a terrible crime and
very few ways to prove it
generally speak and so you have a lot of
people who are victimized
and there was no support for them
because there was no way to prove that
these things happen even if they did
happen often
absolutely but i don't think the answer
to that is to then
go off in the opposite direction and
then just throw a lot of blame at people
without zero proof i mean even when the
evidence is stacked
against the accuser sometimes he'll
still
go with it i know this because even my
time in the military like when i first
joined they said don't get involved with
female service members
it's very risky i took that [ __ ] to
heart
and i had an incident where i never even
came in contact with somebody never
physically close to them
and they try to make some story up
thankfully
there were multiple eyewitnesses that i
had complete strangers
who were there who vouched for what
happened but
i remember just being so angry about the
mud that i got dragged through for the
whole lot
this man's been going through it for
years he got expelled from his
university despite the video evidence
you know they're regarding him as some
kind of and they made him pay for
tuition
of course he's going to feel some type
of way it's hard to let go of that kind
of anger when you didn't do something
and somebody says you did it's a tough
thing in my stomach so
this is one of those things i think when
it comes to all this stuff
um this is why i tell men like what you
guys should do
because it's important for us to take
accountability for the kind of
situations that we put ourselves in as
well okay well
he's the victim let me call it victim
blame call whatever you want i'm just
giving you guys the advice you need
to keep yourself safe all right ladies
do what they do i'm not gonna say
nothing right
but guys if you're in these kind that
you don't if she's drunk
inebriated any kind of don't even think
about it make sure everyone's in the
right state of mind so you guys can go
at it in a
good way i know it's tough because you
go you meet people at bar so it's like
how
hey man i'll be keeping [ __ ] with you
that's why i try not to pick up ladies
from bars
that's not my thing just to avoid this
kind of stuff
because you wake up in the morning all
that regret and you're like did i really
want this i was like i don't want
i don't even want to look at him there's
a lot of messiness out there guys just
take care of yourselves protect
yourselves
you know i think in doing so and being
smarter about this yeah maybe you'll
take a few more rejections yeah things
won't work out but
the fat least you'll make sure that
you're insulated as best as possible
that's pretty much it that's it as far
as this whole thing goes yeah
you know it's funny that like people can
be proven liars with video evidence but
their faces still get blurred out even
though they're the ones
who did that yeah that's what's coming
up
in this no name really no name even
though she's the one who no names no
nothing
really we're gonna protect her because
she lied or whatever
but we're going to blast him right all
right that's crazy
cool all right but like i said like i
said
that's all my thoughts on this there's
still some people well pisses me out
there's there's still some people that
are going to defend this yeah
but i don't talk to crazy people you're
crazy i don't talk to crazy people
out of your mind so it's like people who
think like black folks can never do
wrong they never have a reason to get
pulled over so you know sometimes
you're doing 80 and a 40 all and
sometimes ladies your [ __ ] does stinks
it is what it is i've seen it firsthand
priests have seen it first hand
folks have seen it firsthand so why are
we all pretending like i said i don't do
this whole believe her believe him
believe them believe
jews say nouns where's the facts and the
evidence and we'll stick with that so
that's my thoughts
who knows so let us know what you guys
think in the comments below you guys
ever dealt with this and if so let us
[Music]
know
play
[Music]
no time for fake ones
that keeps you